all right welcome back to my round seven
recap from Vegas I've still had no time
to shave let me know in the comments if
I should shave my beer or not
but anyway
um in this round I was playing Sullivan
McConnell who I haven't heard of before
but uh I think his video rating is
around maybe 2050 or 2100 and I really
didn't have much time between this round
and the previous round if you saw my my
previous round recap it was a super long
game I have about 90 minutes between the
rounds and I spent that time recording
the previous round recap and then
preparing so I didn't actually have time
to eat although I did uh go to the bar
and get some coffee
uh not not beer or wine just yet but um
yeah coffee helps keep me awake for this
game
and yeah let's get into it I played D4
and I did spend maybe about half hour
just sifting through my opponents
chess.com games and I saw that he plays
pretty much everything against the
London but I also saw that in the
previous round
um one of the rounds of this tournament
he played E6 against D4 and then he
played a very quick E6 B6
and that's what he did in this game
after E6 Bishop F4 V6 and I checked this
position before the game and the most
principal move here is actually not to
go for a mainstream London setup with E3
or another three uh but the objectively
best move is to control the center with
E4 so that's what I played he played
Bishop to B7
and I played Bishop to D3 now the reason
why I played Bishop D3 is I checked with
the engine before the game and uh it's
one of the top engine moves and I think
it's one of the trickiest moves even
though it kind of feels weird to develop
both Bishops before either night there
is a point in the eventual line that we
got after he played C5 there is a really
cool idea that I believe might be a
novelty at least in the Masters database
this position has never been reached
before so maybe C5 is a novelty in the
Masters database but I was prepared with
the top engine move here it's to
sacrifice a pawn with D5
the point is if he takes twice takes
takes takes white can very simply play
Knight F3 and there's just very quick
development uh Knight C3 will come with
Tempo e-files open and black is severely
underdeveloped and yeah white has full
compensation I think the engine gave
like plus 0.69 if I'm not mistaken so
it's just a really nice position for
white and
um I think it's just very difficult for
black to play
so let's go back and uh actually see
what happened the game because after D5
he only took once and then he played a
move Queen F6 which I didn't check
before the game but I knew Bishop takes
D5 was the best move according to
stockfish
so I knew that even though Queen F6 it
looks scary because my Bishop my b-pawn
and my d-pawn are all hanging
I basically knew that the valuation has
to be
better than 0.69 so I took some time
here and I decided to not defend any of
these things but rather counter-attack
with Queen E2
and it's a nice in-between move because
it's a little bit awkward for black to
get out of check like if a bishop or
Knight block on E7 then black has to
worry about eventual D6 and I think if
either minor piece blocks let's say
Bishop blocks I was going to start with
this move
and then if Queen G5 hitting this and
this I would play F4 defending and
defending and D6 is coming and yeah I
think this would just be very painful
for black now what happened the game was
also very painful for black because my
opponent had to play Queen E7 and I do
want to note actually if if I toggle the
engine on in this position the engine
already says White's winning so I got a
winning position after seven moves but
there's still a question can I convert
it uh smoothly and uh and not mess it up
so after Queen E7 I very simply play
Knight C3 and just allow the queen trade
I figured that it's not worth going out
of my way to avoid the queen trade and
I'm just enjoying the nice lead in
development uh my opponent played Knight
F6 and then I played Knight to B5 so
seizing the initiative now threatening
nasty Forks like Knight DC 6 and Knight
C7 and at this point I was feeling
really good like White's position is
just a dream and there's no time for
black to take on D5
if takes right away on D5 there's going
to be some fork and if Queen takes E2
Knight takes E2 and Knight takes D5
covering C7
um oh it turns out there's only one
winning move for white in this position
I saw it during the game but I didn't
realize it's the only winning move so if
you want to try and find it feel free to
pause the video white to move and just
win a lot of material
the move is Bishop E4 uh pinning the
Knights of the bishop and just setting
up takes and work and there's no Escape
for black
so yeah black did not take on D5 he did
take on E2 and then he plays Knight A6
so covering C7
but now after C4 I'm just getting a
really nice bind in the position and
I've just had a great space advantage
and blacks pieces are a bit stuck on the
queen side and I was secretly hoping for
Castle queenside in this position so I
could check made in one but that didn't
quite happen my opponent played Bishop
E7 I deliver a check which basically
forces Bach to give away the dark spot
bishop and now my darks for Bishop is a
monster on D6 preventing casting
kingside so I was more expecting
castling Queen side in this position now
I do want to note that I've seen a lot
of people be confused online in like
YouTube comments and twitch shots and
Reddit threads uh no no my Bishop ah
it's a mouse slip
ah
everyone's not falling for it though oh
upon fell for it let's go it's a castle
Fork
because it some people don't think it's
legal to Castle queenside when the B8
square is controlled but it's only
illegal if the king is going through
check if the Rook goes through a square
that's attacked that's totally fine so
this was what I was expecting but white
is still uh very much for Choice here
instead my opponent played King d8
which uh does aim to free the E8 Square
for either the Knight or The Rook but
after King D2 basically both pieces want
to move to the square The Rook wants to
control the file and the Knight wants to
come here to remove the bishop my
opponent chose 98 but after Bishop G3 I
still have a great grip on the position
uh he played H6 Knight C3 Knight C7
rookie one and I'm just gradually
improving uh my dream was to double on
e-file and eventually you get in some
rookie seven
so he played Rook f8 what else to do for
black and then I thought for a little
bit here because initially I wanted to
play like rookie two and double up but
then there's F5 and I have to be careful
of f4 and G5 trapping my Bishop
so I decided to just gain more space on
the king side with the move F4 and even
though it temporarily blocks my Bishop
I'm just preparing F5 and I'm really
just trying to like clamp down like I
kind of felt like um what do you call it
Anaconda like just wrapping around my
opponent so yeah it's very uncomfortable
for black uh my opponent played Knight
F6 I play F5 and then rookie eights so
attempting to trade the Rooks and have a
little bit more space to maneuver but I
prevent The Rook trade with Bishop E5
and I was very happy with this move
because essentially
it's very difficult for black to find
any useful move here and I thought the
position is very close to zuzuong for
black seems like almost every move is
self-destructive in some way and the
move that my opponent played did kind of
self-destruct pretty quickly
um just to show the d-pawn can't really
move the Knight is stuck on C7 Bishop
stuck on B7 Rook stuck in the corner
this Knight is essentially pin to the G7
pawn and I thought maybe my opponent
would play A6 to prepare some B5 but A6
takes away the only
Square left for the knights and then I
just have D6 trapping the Knight on C7
so
yeah super uncomfortable for black my
opponent ends up playing Knight G4 but
this walks into a pretty simple tactical
sequence I took he took Knight B5
forcing the king back to defend the rook
and I did take time here because
I have some options uh after takes takes
I was debating between 96 and Knight C7
ultimately I chose Knight C7 the reason
why I didn't go for Knight D6 was
because my night might get trapped in
the very end like King E7 here and it's
still winning but I didn't want to walk
into such a line where the king will
come and take the knights so I snagged
The Rook on A8
after King d8 Knight takes Bishop takes
and now it's a matter of converting the
material advantage I have Rook for
Knights and the next several moves are a
lot of improving moves
plan is to expand on the king side just
optimize my pawns my rook and um yeah I
found a nice Square for The Rook on E3
essentially going for ideas of Rook A3
but also preparing if black plays
Knights E5 I can drop back to E2 and
then the Rook has access to G3 as well
so he played Bishop B7 I played Bishop
E2 Bishop C8 Rook G3 and my eventual
plan is to play G5 and just eventually
create a weakness on the king side and
there's already a weakness on the queen
side so I thought if I can create a
weakness on both sides of the board
that's one way to uh to win the position
it's called the principle of two we
misses
so after King E7 I optimize my king king
E3 and f8 King F4
he plays F6 and black is just kind of
waiting for his Doom I play rookie three
King d8 and then finally Pawn G5 as a
breakthrough move uh he took I took
Bishop D7 and then Pawn to G6 and even
though it looks like I'm closing things
down I now have the idea of eventually
getting the Rook to H7 where G7 is now a
long-term weakness
um and then he played A5 and
when I had initially played G6 my
intention was to play Rook H3 right away
but then I realized Rook H3 is actually
a serious mistake because it allows
Knight takes G6 and this was my
opponent's final trick in the position
and I do want to give him kudos for not
resigning because I was slightly close
to actually playing Rook H3 not
realizing there's a pin uh White's still
doing well here after King E4 but uh
yeah once I saw Knight takes G6 I I just
wanted to play it safe I started with
Bishop to D1 and uh yeah black is very
much stuck he played Bishop C8 and then
I played Bishop A4 and yeah my opponents
threw in the towel here I think the
Anaconda has successfully squeezed
Black's position rookie this coming and
yeah what to do engine gives plus 14 in
White's favor
so I think overall this was one of my
uh one of my most one-sided games I
would say especially from the opening it
was somewhat of an opening disaster from
my opponent and I was fortunate because
I was really tired going into this game
uh given that my previous round was
almost four and a half hours so it's
nice to have a relatively quick and less
stressful game in round seven
so uh there's two more rounds to go I
think the rounds are going to start
earlier tomorrow they usually start at
11 A.M Pacific but I think tomorrow is
going to be 10 a.m so I think my
priority is to find some food and get
some rest so again thanks so much for
watching if you want to support be sure
to subscribe follow on Twitch you can
check out all of the commentary that
Jonathan trance has been doing also if
you want to get rich I do have the Vegas
coupon code use coupon code Vegas to
save 15 off everything in the merch
store links will be in the description
so again thanks so much for watching and
I'll see you guys in the next recap